we continue this half hour with Pope
Francis's visit to Panama the Pope has
spoken out about the dangers of society
building walls and condemning migrants
but he has not directly addressed the
clergy sexual abuse scandal engulfing
the Catholic Church Seth Doane is
traveling with the Pope flying flags
that show how global this group is
hundreds of thousands of Catholics
packed Panama City streets while Pope
Francis took World Youth Day to those
who could not attend young inmates at a
detention facility the pontiff heard
their confessions Friday and talked
about the danger of walls again this
time the invisible emotional ones the
divider while many of the faithful here
tell us that they are certainly aware of
the pressures at the Catholic Church and
the Pope face when it comes to clerical
sex abuse scandals they say this is not
the place to be discussing Church
policies or politics note they see this
as a party Geraldine Vieira is from
Florida still at Friday evenings somber
way of the cross the Pope discussed
those suffering like youth who quote
fall into the snares of unscrupulous
people including people who claim to be
serving you Lord it was his most direct
reference of the trip to clerical sex
abuse though the subtlety may have been
lost on some at an event dubbed the
Catholic Woodstock there's no doubt who
the star is
and many here are happy to set aside the
scandals and celebrate for CBS this
morning Saturday
Seth Dome Panama City Catholic witness
talk that's great